لا يمكن التنبؤ مشاهدينا بالزلازل قبل
حدوثها لاجل ذلك يصعب تفادي تداعيات
الزلزال الخطره والتي تكون احيانا مدمره
حسب قوته بمقياس ريختر لنلقي مع النظره
العامه حول كيفيه حصول الزلازل يعرف
الزلزال مشاهدينا بانه اهتزاز ارضي مفاجئ
ينتج عن الحركه المستمره للصفائح
التكتونيه والتي تسبب تراكم الضغط على
طبقات الصخور على جانبي الصدوع الواقعه
بين الصفائح مما يؤدي الى تكسر الكتل
الصخريه وانزلاقها فوق بعضها وبالتالي
اطلاق الطاقه المخزنه في القشره الارضيه
في حركه مفاجئه ينتج عنها موجات تحمل طاقه
زلزاليه تنتشر عبر صخور الارض لتصل الى
السطح مما يتسبب بحدوث الاهتزازات
الزلزاليه تتعدد الاسباب الطبيعيه لحصول
الزلازل لتشمل الهزات التكتونيه لطبقات
التكتونيه طبعا التي تعد الاكثر شيوعا
يحدث انجراف قاري وتوسع في قاع المحيط
لينقسم الى عدد من الاجزاء او الصفائح
الصلبه التي تتراوح سماكتتها ما بين مئه
ومئه وخمسين كيلومترا لتتحرك بعدها حركه
مستمره فوق طبقه الغلاف الموري التي تقع
تحت القشره الارضيه هناك ايضا الزلازل
البركانيه التي تحدث بسبب البراكين النشطه
ولكنها ليست بقوه الزلازل التكتونيه
وغالبا ما تحدث بالقرب من سطح الارض ولذلك
يتم الشعور بها فقط بالقرب من نقطه منشا
الزلزال يعقب حدوث الزلازل العديد من
الاحداث والاثار التي قد تكون مدمره ويمكن
ان تتخذ اشكالا متعدده منها الانهيارات
والفيضانات والحرائق وسيل التربه وتسونامي